I'm James May IRAs in Hammond I'm Jeremy
Clarkson and this is the last thing on
my phone
wait that's the name of the segment it's
my penis it's it's my own trousers to
show that's something from the Grand
Tour
it's our changing room it's here in
James okay it's you pulling us at you
porn what was it nobody wants to see
that I mean mine was named Rocco trying
to change the name of my email account
that's interesting isn't it I was
looking for the US Embassy you seriously
had to Google where the US Embassy
wasn't even funny what I didn't find it
was I'm a motorcycle I had to stop and
his parking and got in a taxi and went
150 yards to live in London I also
looked at the weather in Suffolk because
Hammond and I have to go there tomorrow
is it England this rain is it awesome I
stood up as my parole officer what is my
son quite good actually
mine was Gulf Cartel mm why was because
you're just sinking your helicopter is
grounded this week which means you have
to go to Suffolk in you car
[Music]
three wire up 3:06 1706 1906 20s I've
got willows birthday alarm and Mardi
Gras on my times are five five seventeen
five thirty five forty five six six ten
6:30 6:45 7:00 1800 1858 at 1950 we left
them all on I've got oh seven oh one
1803 and 2101 they are tagged dad's
birthday haircut and get up face I have
never used an emoji don't have use every
mode appropriate I just feel wrong to be
using the marianas should James you have
used to me I never use the thumbs up one
occasionally because you can do it in
lots of different colors it's very right
on so you can have it all the way from
sort of pasty Northern Europe into it
you know if somebody from Africa the all
shades of unum I've got the Internet of
music the Pelias and valleys are best
bailius some medieval music to jam
albums and that's all of the same album
that's all of the same album as well
[Music]
Einstein died off planet look back and
do all we can
I'm Stein still died we are what we are
in a time we can conceive and measure
utterly meaningless Kate Winslet's
something to tell us yes diarrhea see
pick on people in bins I suspect it was
there was a story that Kate Winslet was
pregnant they've got a photograph of
maybe a baby bump it's mail online calls
it they'll have got something to tell us
Kate yeah I've got diarrhea just got a
bit of a bloated guy I'm gonna have a
big in a minute mail online
[Music]
111 thousand six hundred and seventy two
I've got just two here's my inbox all of
them unread if you're watching this
Peter drawn Rugby School whoever you are
not every Benjamin Edward Simon Morris
Jeff Bezos unread embarrassing yeah